[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طائر البركه
احييكم وهذه هي العربيات 360 حيث الخبر من
كل زواياه ومن جميع جوانبه
رونالدو يمارس هوايته المفضله البرتغالي
يكتب تاريخا جديدا اول لاعب يسجل في خمسه
بطولات في خمس بطولات كاس عالم
رغم التحضيرات الروسيه والامريكيه تركيا
تؤكد تناسقها بعمليه عسكريه شمال سوريا
وقسد تحذر من عوده داعش
والدينا ايضا في العربيه 360
المسيرات المدنيه جواسيس الصين في واشنطن
والكونغرس يدعو الى تحرك عاجل
[موسيقى]
قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اجور كوناشن كوفر ان قوتي بلاده لم توجه
اي ضربه لاهداف في كياف مشيرا الى ان
الدمار الذي اعلنته اوكرانيا
ناتج عن صواريخ الدفاع الجوي الاوكرانيا
المنتشره في المناطق السكانيه بحسب
تعبيرعبيره
ضربه واحده
كل الدمار الذي اعلنه النظام الاوكراني
داخل المدينه نتاجا عن سقوط صواريخ
اطلقتها انظمه دفاع جوي اجنبي واوكرانيه
منتشره في مناطق سكنيه بالعاصمه الاخرانيه
رغم ان في موسكو الا ان الجيش الروسي متهم
بمواصله استهداف قطاع الطاقه في اوكرانيا
تحضيره لشتاء قاسم قادما للطرفين
المتحاربين غداه الضربات التي تسببت في
اوسع انقطاعات للتيار في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه منذ نشوب الحرب استمر انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي عن اكثر من ثلثي كياف
اضافه لغياب امدادات المياه العاصمه كانت
من بين الاهداف الرئيسيه لموجه الهجمات
الاخيره على منشات الطاقه ما دفع السلطات
لقطع الخدمه عن عده مناطقه لترشيد استهلاك
الطاقه واجراء الاصلاحات اللازمه مع
اقتراب الشتاء رئيس بلديه
كافكو قال ان الفنيين يعملون لاعاده
التيار باسرع ما يمكن لكنه اوضح ان اعادته
تعتمد الى حد كبير على توازن الطاقه في
اجمالي الشبكه الوطنيه داعيا السكان الى
تخزين ما يكفي من الماء والطعام
والامدادات لفصل الشتاء
[موسيقى]
اذن اربعه قتلى جراء قصف روسيه على مدينه
خيرسون وفقا لحاكم خرسان الاوكرانيه هذه
المدينه التي انسحب منها الروس مؤخرا
روسيا تستعد لتجميد الاوكرانيين لكن لم
يعد بامكانها الاعتماد على الشتاء بحسب
مجله بوليتيكو اضافه المجله ان روسيا تريد
استعاده ذكريات التاريخ عندما ساعدها
الشتاء على ايقاف جيشين نابليون وهتلر ومن
المفترض ان يكون الشتاء صديقا جيدا للقوات
الروسيه لكن لم يكن الحال كذلك دائما
بنسبه لروسيا فالشتاء لم يقف بجانبهم عام
1940 عندما قلب الفنلنديون الطاوله عليهم
خلال حربهم الشتويه انا ذاك انه قد هو
المحللون العسكريون توقعوا لاشهر ان
الشتاء سيحدث فجوه في القتال على الجبهات
الاماميه الاوكرانيه وان طاطا الروسيه
تقضي باضعاف معنويات المدنيين الاوكرانيين
من خلال قطع الكهرباء والتدفئه فيما يسعى
الاوكرانيون للاستفاده من التجنيد الروسي
سيء التجهيز وفي حين انه من المتوقع عموما
ان تتباطئ وتيره القتال الا ان القتال لم
يتوقف في المناطق الشرقيه من دونيتسكو
ولجانسك على الرغم من درجات الحراره
المتدنيه
قوله ان المعارك تدور ليلا ونهارا بغض
النظر عن الطقس مضيفا ان القتال بالقرب من
مخموت يتارجح بين كر وفر من الجانبين كما
اوضحت وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان الخطه
تهدف الى مواصله الضغط خلال الشتاء وربما
الاستفاده من هذا الفصل ومحاوله الوصول
الى شبه جزيره القرم
الاوكرانيون يريدون البناء على الزخم
العسكري الذي حققوه حققوه مؤخرا بالتقدمات
التي حققوها حول خارقيف وخيرسون ما يجعل
القرن في مرمى صواريخهم
عن معهد دراسه الحرب الامريكي ان الشتاء
مع تجمد التضاريس سيساعد كلا الجانبين على
المناوره لكن من المحتمل ان يكون للتقص
البارد اثر على القوات الروسيه
ومعداتها الرديئه وذكر المعهد بل ذكر بفشل
التقدم الروسي نحو كياف في الشتاء الماضي
توقع المعهد ان يعمد الروس الى بناء قوات
على الحدود البلا روسيه شمال كياف مره
اخرى في محاوله لكسب او لسحب القوات
الاوكرانيه بالاحرى بعيدا عن خط المواجهه
في الجنوب والشرق تقييم معهد دراسه الحرب
اشار الى انه من المرجح ان يكون الشتاء
بجانب الاوكرانيين بسبب نقص او انعدام
الخبره لدى المجندين ضمن التعبئه الجزئيه
الاخيره بينما تعمل موسكو على تدري في
قواتها وتجهيزها بعد ما نشر مجندون على
موقع تلجرام مقاطع لظروف السيئه التي
يواجهونها من بين امور اخرى ورد ان القوه
الروسيه بدات في تلقي ستره واقيه من
الرصاص اضافه الى خوذات ايرانيه الصنع لكن
من غير المرجح ان تضاهي جوده الملابس
والعتاد الغربي المقدم لاوكرانيا على سبيل
المثال اعلنت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه
رساله مئه وخمسه
و900.000 طقم للشتاء اذا مئه وخمسه وتسعين
الفن من الاطم للشتاء كما يقوم شركاء
غربيون اخرون بتوريد مولدات محموله وخيام
تكفي ل 200,000 جندي اكرامي
الفصل الاخير في الحرب بين روسيا
واوكرانيا لم يكتب بعد لكن مشرعا روسيه
لديه تصور لمشهد ختامي وان طال الزمن
قال ان على روسيا السعيا الى تحقيق
العداله بمفردها على حد قوله وان توصل
الرئيس الاوكراني مع دائرته الى حبل
المشنقه
اشار الى ان موسكو قد تلاحق الرئيس
الاوكراني مع دائرته الداخليه مدى الحياه
وخلال لقاء تلفزيوني قال النائب نازل
انسكي والمحيطين به ربما تكون لديهم منازل
سريه في مكان ما من العالم لكن يجب ان
تطالهم يدرس روسيا نذكره
مطلوب لدى الشرطه البريطانيه لقتله جاسوسا
سابقا في لندن عام 2006 هو الضابط السابق
في المخابرات الروسيه الكساندر لتبانكو
باستخدامي ماده البولونيوم المشعه تحدثنا
كثيرا انا ذات عن هذا الموضوع تذكرون خلص
تحقيق البريطانيه عام 2016 الى ان القتل
ربما تمت الموافقه عليه من قبل رئيس
المخابرات الروسيه انا ذاك نيكولاي
باتروسيف مع الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتن
ههه
سوريا سوريا
طبعا في المقطع الصوتي الاخير اشار النائب
الروسي اا اندريه لجوفاي الى بابل سودو
بلاتوف وهو ضابط استخبارات سوفيتي راحل
كان المخطط لعمليه اغتيال ليون ترانسكي
احد قاده الثوره البلشفيه الى جانب لمين
وبعد وفاه الاخير حاول ستالين التخلص من
اي معارضه داخليه قد يسببها التروسكوب لكن
الاخير ماذا فعل هرب الى المكسيك واصبح
معارضا من الخارج الا ان عملاء الاتحاد
السوفيتي لاحقوه الى هناك وقتلوه قصه
الخلاف بين ستالين والتريكسكيلي عشاق
الادب الانجليزيه تحديدا هي التي خلدها
الروائي البريطاني الراحل جورج
رمزيته في روايته الشهيره مزرعه الحيوان
ينضم الينا قسطنطينيه البحث في العلاقات
الدوليه الان اهلا بك معنا استاذ قسطنطين
في العربيه
360 هل ااه يعني ياخذون هذا الكلام الى
توقع
عمليات او محاولات القيام بعمليات اغتيال
حقيقيه اضافيه لما تم سابقا وتكلمنا عنه
للرايزنسكي ودائرته المقربه فعلا كمحاوله
تغيير الموقف لصالح روسيا من قبلها طبعا
اقصد
شكرا على هذه مقدمه تاريخيه مفصله هناك
اكيد ان روسيا تستخدم مقارنات التاريخيه
التي بمصلعتها
بمصلحتها لي مثلا اييي
ي
تقديم رؤيه المستقبل الذي
الان في وضع
الدولي هو صفاته الدوليه اسوى بكثير من من
موقف اوكرانيا
بغرض النازل عن المشاكل التي سببت الروسيه
في اوكرانيا نتيجه لهذه الاستهلافات
المنشات المدنيه معنويات اوكرانيا
وكرانيين عاليه
تضامن الشركاء حولها ايضا قوي جدا اما
بالنسبه لروسيا فهناك مشاكل حتى ما
خلفائها مثل الصين وكثير من الدول الاخرى
اا نظرا
لا اطاله هذه الحركه اوكرانيا
الجرائم الجرائم المتعدده التي ارتكبها
ولكن هناك عوامل ضعف منها القوه الروسيه
منها الحلفاء للرؤوس منها ايضا اللحظات
المفصليه التي تقدم فيها بعض الدول عاده
الكثير من التنازلات القاسيه حتى لو كانت
مع حلفائها وحتى لو كان راسا لنظام مقابل
ما هو اكبر لصالحها ما رايك
نعم فا هناك دول التي تقدم تنازلات
اوكرانيا كانت في بدايه الحرب ااا يعني
قبل كل هذه الجرائد
والاعمال العشوائيه التي قامت بها روسيا
في بلادنا كانت جائزه لتنازلات كانت جائزه
[موسيقى]
بتقديم اي تنازلات للمعتدي لدوله
الارهابيه التي قتلت اثرت عليهم من
المدنيين نساء واطفال
والشيوخرانيه ههه انا اقصد تنازلات من
حلفائكم ان راوا ان ذلك في صالحهم
الاستراتيجي في العلاقه مع روسيا بمعنى
التخلي عنكم
لا هناك اي دلائل على ذلك
فبالنسبه لتنازلات الغرب
ااا
اللي يحصل في في الاسابيع الاخيره وعنصر
الاخيره كل ما ترتكب في روسيا جرائم الحرب
الجديده كل ما يزيد الحلفاء دعمهم
لاوكرانيا بما فيها امدادات الاسلحه او
مساعدات الماليه
هذه الحرب في اوكرانيا اصبحت نقطه
تاريخيه بالنسبه
لاغلبيه الخلفاء
من الواقع ايضا ومن المنطقه التفكير بانه
اوكرانيا ستستعيد كل اراضيها في مثل هذه
الحرب على الاقل شبه جزيره القرم يعني
لبعض يستثنيها حتى لو عادت بعض المناطق
الاخرى
نعم هناك توقعات كبيره نحو ذلك كما كما
تقول في بدايه الحرب لم لم تخطط اوكرانيا
على ذلك
كانت جاهزه جاهزه لتقديم التنازلات فيما
يخص يعني مناقشه صفه شبه جزيره القرم ولكن
الاهداف
الاخير لم تاتي لم تعطي لها مجالا مناورات
ولم تعطي لها مجالا لتفاوض مع روسيا شكرا
جزيلا لك قسطنطينيه
تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
اليوم الخامس من منافسات كاس العالم في
قطر كانت البدايه بمباراه سويسرا
والكاميرون حيث فاز المنتخب السويسري
بنتيجه هدف لي لا شيء المباراه الثانيه
كانت محبطه الى حد كبير بين الاوروغواي
وكوريا الجنوبيه وانتهت بتعادل دون اهداف
اما المباراه الاخيره بين البرتغال وغانا
فكانت اشبه بالتعويض حيث شهدت خمسه اهداف
وانتهت بفوز البرتغال بثلاثه اهداف لهدفين
وفي هذه الاثناء تجرى مباراه بين ابرز
المرشحين للفوز بالبطوله اي المنتخب
البرازيلي الذي يواجه حاليا نظيره الصربيا
اجواء هذه المباراه والمباريات الاخرى
اليوم واجواء الجماهير في منطقتهم الخاصه
بهم او الخاصه بالفيفا وبهم كذلك منطقه
الجماهير الخاصه بالفيفا فضه العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي اهلا بك معنا عبد المحسن
الكلمه لك
نعم طاهر بالفعل انتقلت الاجواء الان الى
مباراه البرازيل في هنا اطلالاتها في هذا
في هذه البطوله في كاس العالم الكثير من
المشجعين المحبين البرازيل قد يموت عصام
مروان هذه
الساعه
المنتخب البرازيلي في اطارته الاولى بعد
الحلقه كريستيانو رونالدو الى انتصاراته
في المباراه السابقه بعد انكسرت البرتغال
على قالها بمباراه صعبه
كثير جدا والاف من الجماهير الذين فضلوا
الحضور الى هذه الى هذا المكان
والاستمتاع بمشاهده المباراه في هذه
المنطقه فانفاستيفال الخاصه ب فيفا التي
خصصتها الجمهور هنالك طاهره همم قبل ان
اعود اليك ولكن الان احد الجماهير من
المكسيك قال بانه يريد ان يتحدث عن
المنتخب السعودي واهدائه خلال المباراه
السابقه
سعودي السلام عليكم
[ضحك]
البرنس ههه
الاجواء المنتخب السعودي في الحقيقه صنع
حاله
وحاله رائعه جدا في كاس العالم
المنتخب السعودي
مع المكسيك يعني
المنتخب السعودي من قبل المنتخبات الاخرى
يعني يحسب لها الكثير من الحسابات همم
طبعا يتحدثون بالايجاب عن الاداء السعودي
في المنتخب همم الاخير همم واعتقد انه هذا
هو المشهد العام عندك كيف يقضي المشجعون
اوقاتهم في خارج نطاق المباريات التي
يريدون تشجيعها او يشاهدونها
نعم بالفعل قبل قليل عن المسجل المكسيكي
الذي نلتقيين ابيه عن فخري بما فعله
المنتخب السعودي في الحقيقه الاجواء همم
هؤلاء المشجعين القادمين الى هذه المنطقه
منطقه الخاصه بفيفا قال بيتهم اما انهم
ارادوا الاستمتاع بهذه الاجواء في هذه
المنطقه او لم يحصلوا على التذاكر فيريده
ان يحصلوا او يذهبوا الى منطقه تجمع كبير
للجماهير كما تشاهد الانواع واحده من
الازمات في البرازيل هنالك حماس كبير جدا
عندما همم يسجل احد المنتخبات هدفا في هذه
المنطقه تشعر وكانك في الملعب همم صخر
كبير جدا بالاضافه الى وجود حفلات غنائيه
لفنانين عالميين من مختلف انحاء العالم
وحمالات صاخبه بين همم المباريات وبعدها
اللي يحفظ المشجعون في
قطر بتجربه استثنائيه في الحقيقه طاهر همم
سواء كان في داخل الملاعب او حتى في
المناطق المخصصه للجماهير هنا في همم
كورنيش الدوحه تحديدا في هذه الحديقه
ايضا في سياق العربيه 360 بعد قليل وفي
سياق كل نشراتنا الاخرى خاصه رياضيه منها
من منطقه الجماهير الخاصه بالفيفا في
الدوحه موفد العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي
في العربيه 360 ايضا
تركي ان تؤكد لروسيا انها متمسكه بتنفيذ
عمليه بريه في سوريا
وتقارب بين انقره والنظام يضع الاكراد في
موقف صعب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ابلغ وزير الدفاع
التركيه خلصي اكار نظيره الروسيه في اتصال
الهاتف فيه انقره ستواصل الرد على الهجمات
التي تنطلق من شمال سوريا بعد طلب موسكو
من انقره تجنبه هجوم واسع النطاق في سوريا
واكد اكار ضروره الالتزام بالاتفاقيات
السابقه بشان شمال سوريا مشيرا الى ان
اولويه تركيه هي درع ما وصفها بالتهديدات
الارهابيه من شمال سوريا بشكل دائم
ضمن عمليه المخلب السيف لا تلبس طائره
حربيه تركيه منذ فجر الاحد الا وتوجه
ضرباتها ضد المقاتلين الاكراد في سوريا
والعراق وبعد مرور ايام على غارات طالت
عشرات المواقع في مناطق نفوذ القوات
الكرديه اعربت الولايات المتحده عن قلقها
العميق ازاء الاعمال العسكريه الاخيره
التي تهدد استقرار المنطقه حيث حظا ناطق
باسمي وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه على ضروره
وقف فوريه لتصعيد مضيفا انه واشنطن تتفهم
ان لدى انقر مخاوف امنيه لكنه اكد ان
عملياتها اثرت بشكل مباشر على سلامه
العسكريين في المنطقه اما وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه فاكدت ان الاحداث التي يشهدها
العراق وشمال سوريا تهدد مهمه التصدي
لتنظيم داعش على جانبي الحدود
وبينما طقس في تركيا بلا هواده يخشى اكراد
سوريا ان تغض سلطات النظام السوريه عنهم
الطرف فهي لم تبدي موقفا صار منتجه
الضربات المتوسطه واكتفت بذكري عدد القتلى
بلا تعليق اخر حتى الان لا تبدو ملامح
العلاقه بين تركيا والنظام واضحه
فالمحللون يتوقعون بان القطيعه التي
استمرت 11 سنه قد تتبدد تدريجيا خلال
المرحله المقبله اي تماما حينما شبت
الاحتجاجات في مارس عام 2011 عندما كانت
النقطه الفارقه التي قلبت العلاقه بينهما
قبل ذلك كانت تركيا حليفا لسوريا حلفا
اقتصاديا سياسيا اساسيا لسوريا والصداقه
بين بشار الاسد ورجب طيب اردوغان كانت في
اوجه الان انا الاوان لان يعود هذا
التقارب بحسب محللين سياسيين رجحوا ان
هناك مؤشرات تقارب بين الطرفين بواسطه
روسيه اعدا عن تصريح اردوغان الاخير بان
احتمال لقاء الاسد لم يعد مستبعدا قائلا
الا مجال للنقمه في السياسه في نهايه
المطاف
[موسيقى]
لنا عوده لاحقا عندما يجهز ضيفنا الى هذا
الموضوع ولكن نتحول الى موضوع اخر الان
فقد اعلنت وزاره السياحه السعوديه عن
انتخاب المملكه رئيسا للمجلس التنفيذي
لمنظمه السياحه العالميه التابعه للامم
المتحده وذلك خلال اجتماع الدوره المئه
وسبعه عشر التي عقدت بمراكش في المغرب
لتصبح السعوديه اول دوله خليجيه تشغل هذا
المنصب بدوره قال وزير السياحه احمد
الخطيب ان المملكه تدعم جهودا المنظمه
للترويجي للقطاع السياحي حيث تعهدت بانفاق
800 مليار دولار على شكل استثمارات حكوميه
في قطاع السياحه بحلول عام 20 30
وكذلك اكد وزير السياحه السعوديه ان
المملكه ستواصل دعمها لجهود اعاده تصميم
القطاع السياحي بما يساعد على تعزيز النمو
المستدام ومجابهه التحديات المستق يا
بكفاءه
ينضم الينا من مراكش وزير السياحه
السعوديه احمد الخطيب اهلا بكم ما معنا
معالي الوزير في العربيه
360 ومبروك هذا الفوز للسعوديه كاول دوله
خليجيه ماذا يعني لكم ذلك بعد كل الجهود
التي قمتم بها على هذا الصعيد
الله يبارك فيكم وشكرا جزيلا على اتحاد
الفرصه لاننا الظهر معكم اليوم اجتمع
المجلس التنفيذي لمنظمه الصحه العالميه
وناقشنا بنود الاجتماع ومن ضمنها همم
الموافقه على مقترح المملكه لتاسيس فريق
يعمل على اعاده رسم السياحه في المستقبل
وتعزيز
وتحسين اداء المنظمه السياح العالميه
وكذلك ولله الحمد همم طرح همم الموضوع
انتخاب الرئيس همم للمجلس التنفيذي
والنائب الرئيس الاول ونائب الرئيس الثاني
واجتمع الاعضاء ال 35 همم دوله اعضاء
المجلس التنفيذي بالاجماع على ترشيح
المملكه لهذا الموسم وهذا يؤكد مكانه
المملكه
همم ثقتهم همم خطط المملكه وبرؤيه
لاعلنت عنها المملكه في القطاع المعالي
الوزير يعني السعوديه كانت اعلنت عن
استثماراتها على هذا النطاق وهو ما تحد
اشرنا اليه قبل قليل في سياق الخبر ولكن
بالنسبه الى منظمه السياحه العالميه ماذا
يعني ان تكون السعوديه رئيسا للمجلس
التنفيذي من خلال الدور الذي ستقوم به ما
هو يعني تحدثتم سابقا حضرتكم عن اطلاق
المبادرات ودعم الافكار الجديده وافتتاح
اول مكتب اقليمي للمنظمه في السعوديه هل
لنا ان نتخيل يعني بعضا من تطبيق العملي
لهذا الكلام
مهم جدا انه المنظمات تصبح اقوى اليوم
منظمه السياح العالميه هي اضعف منظمه
واصغر منظمه من بين منظمات المنظمات
التابعه للامم المتحده ويهم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بتوجيه قيادتها الكريمه
انه نتيجه لضغط المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الاستثمارات كبيره جدا في القطاع خلال
العشر سنوات القادمه كجزء من رؤيه 20 30
وهو فتح القطاع فتح القطاع السياحه
والتنويع الاقتصاد السعودي يهم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه انه تكون المنظمه منظمه
قويه وبناء عليه وترقص في المملكه للمجلس
التنفيذي سيسهل
لجمع الدول الاعضاء في المجلس التنفيذي
وعلى اجنده تختم القطاع على المد المتوسط
والبعيد
همم يعني ما بعرف عندي احساس انه وكانه
الفائده يعني
مجلس يعني صحح لنا اذا كان ذلك خطا
الفائده للمجلس كانها يعني اكثر من
الفائده للسعوديه مع كل مشاريع التي تقوم
بها في الداخل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بالتاكيد اكبر
دوله مستقبله في القطاع خلال العشر سنوات
الماضيه همم القادمه وهذا معلن عنه الان
ال- ال- المجلس التنفيذي هذا جهاز مهم جدا
لجمع الدول اا سواء همم الدول الاعضاء في
المنظمه همم ومن اهم دول مجموعه ال 20 همم
لها تمثيل كبير في المجلس التنفيذي وبناء
عليه توحيد التوجهات الدعم القطاع همم وضع
همم المعايير والاسس اللي تخلي القطاع
يتفادى كوارث في المستقبل زي ما حضر حصل
في كارثه همم خلال السنوات الماضيه همم
هذا يجعل دور المملكه مهم جدا والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه اعتادت انها تعطي وتعطي
الكثير وبناء عليه وجودنا في رئاسه هذا
المجلس التنفيذي سيجعل من المن اقوى ويجعل
من اعضاء المجلس اكثر همم يعملون بشكل
اكثر تناغما
واستقرارا ليوم في صراعات كبيره في همم
المجلس التنفيذي همم البنوك تاخذ مننا وقت
طويل واعتقد انه جزء كبير من همم اللي
يحصل الان هو ضعف في التنسيق قبل
الاجتماعات المجلس وعدنا الدول الاعضاء
انه المملكه العربيه السعوديه بصفتها
الرئيس الدوره القادمه راح اعمل على تحسين
اداء المجلس التنفيذي بما يعزز من دور
المنظمه ويخدم مصالح الدول الاعضاء وكنتم
ايضا بالاول لرئيس المجلس التنفيذي همم
يعني هذا المنصب يعني ليس بجديد حتى لو
كان الرئاسه الان ولكن يعني انتم في صلب
هذا العمل سابقا ولكن على صعيد ال- همم
800 مليار دولار استثمارات على همم على
شكل استثمارات حكوميه في قطاع السياحه من
الان وحتى او من قبل حتى العام
30 اا يعني الكثير من القرارات في
السعوديه حول هذا الموضوع هل يمكن ان يكون
هناك ما زال همم يعني بالامكان ان تخص صن
به فيما يتعلق
بالقرارات التي يمكن ان تصدر قريبا ومن
الان حتى 20 30 فيما يتعلق بهذا التطور
الكبير الذي تشهده السياحه السعوديه طبعا
السياحه في العالم تساهم ب 10% من اقتصاد
العالم و10% من وظائف العالم وفي المملكه
العربيه السعوديه مساهمتها بحدود 4% فهمم
هناك فرصه كبيره جدا للنمو الى المتوسط
العالمي بحلول 20 30 والنمو هذا ما راح
يجي الا من خلال اخر الاستمارات من همم
وتطوير الوجهات يعني تطوير واجهه البحر
الاحمر من خلال مشاريع كبيره جدا سواء
القطاع العام او القطاع الخاص زي مشروع
الوسط جدا على البحر الاحمر مشروع البحر
الاحمر وامال واا مشاريع التابعه لهم
ذلك المشاريع الاخرى زي الدرعيه والقديه
واخر مشروع اعلن عنه السوده والعلا فهناك
مشاريع كبيره جدا رح تساهم في رفع مساهمه
القطاع في جبال الناتج المحلي للمملكه
العربيه السعوديه الى مستوى المتوسط
العالمي ونطمح باكثر من ذلك الاسبوع
القادم همم المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والرياض تستضيف قمه السفر والسياحه
العالميه وباذن الله راح يكون في اعلانات
ما اقدر اصلح فيها الان ولكن راح يكون في
كشف لمجموعه من المشاريع العملاقه التي
ستخدم هذا القطاع بشكل كبير المهم جدا همم
يعني على الاقل عرفنا بذلك الان وننتظر
هذه الاعلانات شكرا جزيلا لك وزير السياحه
السعوديه احمد الخطيب من مراكش تحياتي لك
شكرا
[موسيقى]
نعود الى الملف السوري الضيف
وهو معنا من باريس الباحث السياسي اهلا بك
معنا دكتور اريد ان يعني ابدا اقعد معك
الى ما تحدثنا عنه قبل قليل وهو وزير
الدفاع التركي الذي ابلغ نظيره الروسي في
اتصال هاتفي بان يعني تركيا ستواصل الرد
على الهجمات ولكن موضوع العمليه البريه
يبدو انه ما تقيمه هل بعد ما حكي عن رفض
امريكي روسي
تراجعت تركيا
اهلا بك عزيزي طاهر والمشاهدي قناه
العربيه يعني انا قراءه ان هذه العمليه هي
بشكل اساسي هدفها الغير المعلن ولكن الاول
ربما الوحيد بشكل اساسي هو الانتخابات
التركيه المقبله وبالتالي يعني هذا يتوقف
على امكانيه ما تقدمه هذه العمليه
العسكريه من ضمانات لاردوغان والحكومه
التركيه الحاليه وحزبه في الفوز بهذه
الانتخابات وبالتالي قد تستدعي هذه
العمليه حشد اكبر وهذا يمكن همم تستفيد
تركيا ايضا من جمله اشياء من ضمنها انشغل
روسيا بالحرب الاوكرانيه وبالتالي يعني
همم تصريحات روسيا لا تؤخذ همم تهديد
حقيقي وكبير همم وبيخص ان روسيا صاحبه
الكثير من قواتها في في سوريا وتركيا اذن
هدفها هنا وايضا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ال- ال- يعني التي شاهدنا فيها
انتخابات نصفيه همم وان فاز فيها يعني
الديمقراطيون بمجلس الشيوخ الا ان
جمهوريين فازوا بمجلس نواب يعني عوده
الجمهوريين بشكل او باخر والامور في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه غير مستقره
تماما
بكل النتائج التي تم تحقيقها على الارض مع
همم الاكراد همم هناك خاصه بملف داعش
لا ولكن هناك خطاب قديمه ليست هي المره
الاولى التي
تهاجم فيها روسيا تركيا سوريا حتى برا
وبالتالي العمليه هنا تاتي بشكل اساسي
هناك طبعا يعني لا شك ان الهدف انتخابي
لكن الهدف القديم ايضا لتركيا في في في
سوريا بالاضافه الى الى السيطره على
الشمال السوري هناك ايضا رغبه بتحديد همم
يعني يقول لوجود الكردي السوري في اراضيها
وبمعنى اخر فصل ذلك الوجود الممكن او
الامتداد الممكن اللي اكراد سوريا مع
اكراد تركيا ووضع عازل العربي بين الاكراد
سوريا واكراد تركيا ذلك العازل يتجلى
بالمنطقه الامنه التي تعمل روسيا على
اقامتها وبنائها وانشائها بمعنى خلق هذا
العازل ما بين اكراد سوريا
والاكراد في تركيا وهذه العمليه التي لم
تنجز بشكل كامل يمكن ل- اا تركيا ان تتقدم
فيها بمعنى اخر انها ربما عصفوران بحجر
واحد ال الانتخابات بشكل اساسي والاستمرار
على المشروع القديم وهو اولا ااا فصل
الاكراد عن بعضهم البعض في تركيا وسوريا
التخلص من السوريين الكثر الذين هاجروا
الى تركيا بعادتهم الى الشمال السوري وهي
حجه انتخابيه اساسيه لان سواء حكومه
اردوغان وسوانا المعارضه هناك امتعاط كبير
من التواجد السوري للمهاجرين والنازحين
واليها وبالتالي هو يريد اعاده هؤلاء
السوريين بوضعهم كفاصل بتصور بين اكراد
سوريا واكراد تركيا والظروف الان الدوليه
سواء في روسيا وعن في سوريا سوا سوا في
تركيا
دائما صعب في هذا الموضوع خاصه عندما تكون
صديقا لعدوين في حاله الولايات المتحده مع
تركيا والقوات الكرديه شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور خلدون النبواني البحث السياسي من
باريس
كالعربيه 360 ايضا
للصين مئات الجواسيس في واشنطن طائرات
مسيرات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد قد تكون الطائرات
المسيره المدنيه مجرده اداه للتصوير
الاحترافي او الترفيه بالنسبه لمعظم
مستخدمها لكن بحسب فولتيكو يبدو ان
الطائرات المسيره الصينيه لها اغراض اخرى
حيث باتت هذه المسايرات رقيبه ربما على
المجال الجوي الاكثر امانا في العالم
ونعني بذلك العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن
واكدت ان اسرابا من هذه الطائرات صينيه
الصنع عكرت صفوه سمائي واشنطن واثارت
بوجودها مخاوف لدى وكاله الامن القومي في
ان تصبح وسيله للتجسس
وبنيه المزاعم استنادا الى مقابلات مع
سبعه من المسؤولين الحكوميين في الكونجرس
الذين اكدوا انهم لاحظوا اكثر من 100
عمليه في فتره الايام ال 45 الاخيره
ووفق الصحيفه فان هذه الطائرات لاستطلاعيه
تصنعها شركه دي جي اي الصينيه وهي اكبر
شركه مصنعه للطائرات من دون طياره شخصيه
والمهنيه في العالم وتشكل المنتجاتها
غالبيه الطائرات ترفيهيه في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
يقول المسؤولون انهم غير واثقين تماما من
ان الاسرابا مواجهه من قبل الحكومه
الصينيه الا انها تمثل منعطفا جديدا في
انتشار الطائرات من دون طيار رخيصه نسبيا
ولكنها متطوره بشكل يتجاوز استخدامها حدد
ترفيه والتجاره وعلى حد تعبير راشد ستون
نائبه رئيس البرامج البحثيه في مركز سمسم
فهذه الطائرات تتمكن من جمع بيانات هائله
قد تكون للوهله الاولى قد تكون مهمتها
بريئه وغير منهجه لكنها بالتاكيد قد ينتهي
بها الامر لمستوى اكثر خطوره بالروم من ان
الشركه المصنعه تؤكد التزامها ببرمجتها
هذه المسيارات بالقيود التي تمنعها من
التحليق فوق المناطق الامنيه في واشنطط
[موسيقى]
صوره اليوم في العربيه 360 من استاد
الجنوب في الدوحه الذي شهد مباراه المنتخب
السويسري امام نظيره الكاميروني
احرز المهاجم السويسري بريل امبولو هدف
فوز سويسرا الوحيد في المباراه لم يحتفل
بعد ذلك فقد احرز الهدف في شباك بلده
الاصلي الكاميرون موقفه صعب جدا حينما ركض
نحوه زملائه للاحتفال بدا وانه يريد
الاعتذار على تسجيل الهدف في منتخب البلد
الذي ولد فيه فهو من مواليد دياواندي
عاصمه الكاميرون ثم نشا بعد ذلك في سويسرا
تماما هي لعنه الهويات القاتله التي تحدث
عنها امين معلوف في كتابه تحت هذا العنوان
الهويه القاتله تصريح اليوم في العربيه
360 للمتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه
الذي تحدث عن محاولات مجموعه السبع وضع
سقفا لسعر النفط الروسي يقول بسكوب ان هذه
المحاولات الغربيه تسعى للوصول الى قرار
من اجل القرار فقط دون وجود امكانيه
لتحويل الامر الى واقع اضافه
الغرب نفسه لا يعرف سعر هذا السقف الذي
يريد فرضه
سيستثنى ويلزم من وكيف سيلزم روسيا
انها قضيه معقده
فيديو اليوم في العربيه 360 من السعوديه
تحديدا من المسجد الحرام في مكه المكرمه
الذي تعرض لتساقط الامطار كناطقه اخرى في
السعوديه اليوم في الحرم المكي عامه
السكينه المشهد
المصلونه والمعتمرون وصلوا اداء مناسكهم
دون توقف فكان المشهد ساحرا
هكذا نكون قد وصلنا الى ختام العربيه 360
ولكن اخبار الساعه لا تنقطع يتابع فيها
معكم الزمن العادن عادل عادل
[ضحك]
جديد
اهلا وسهلا
اليوم لدينا الملفات عديده من ايران الى
تركيا الى التوترات كل هذه المنطقه هذه
الابتسامه الوحيده قد تكون في الدوحه همم
بالنسبه لبعض الجماهير ولكنها ايضا
ابتسامه غاليه
الايام المقبله
[موسيقى]